[Musique]
s'il a l'air fermé c'est pour mieux
protéger ses collections d'œuvres d'art
de la moiteur des tropiques mais pour le
plus grand bonheur du visiteur curieux
il ouvrira ses salles il découvrira
alors les richesses du musée
mais de
Quever his quelquun fait de la
botaniqueom
ce n'est pas d'un peintre que ce musée
tient son nom mais d'un poète le prince
des poètes comme il fut baptisé en 1898
à la mort de
malarmé né à Saint-Denis le 31 mars 1838
le jeune Maré Victor Léon quitte la
réunion à 15 ans avec son oncle il par
le cœur gros d'avoir été conduit par sa
cousine marieéloïse dont il est amoureux
fou à Paris il abandonne très vite ses
études d'ingénieur pour ne se consacrer
qu'à la poésie
il publie son premier recueil aspiration
à 20 ans il rentre ensuite au pays mais
sa bien-aimée se marier à un autre
nouveau chagrin qui le ramène à Paris
après de années de voyage à travers le
monde dans la capitale il s'assure un
succès poétique en 1864 avec poèmes et
poésies d'inspiration parnaienne plus
tard ses lèvres closes sont également
salué par la
critique en 1868 sa famille est ruinée
par la crise économique qui s à la
Réunion il trouve un emploi au chemin de
fer puis dans l'administration grâce à
François de Mailli et mène dès lors une
vie
modeste après quelques essais dans le
théâtre il cesse d'écrire faute
d'inspiration il tentera une nouvelle
fois de conquérir le cœur de Marie
Eloïse à leur veuve nouvel échec après
un bref séjour à la Réunion en
1892 il restera à Paris jusqu'à la fin
de sa vie ne vivant plus que d'une
pension que lui a accordé le Conseil
Général de la Réunion
[Musique]